So let's look at the solution
of our MSYNC quiz.
This processor allows all
possible reorderings.
However, it only allows reorderings
of accesses to different locations
because cache coherence and
correct uniprocessor behavior ensures
that accesses to the same variable
are still done in correct order.
So we don't have to
worry about the LL and
SC and this store being reordered
with respect to each other.
They're still going to behave exactly
as if they were in program order.
However, the variable and the lock
are different memory locations so
they can be arbitrarily reordered here.
So what can happen is that this
load of a variable could be
moved all the way up,
before we even try to acquire the lock.
So now we are loading potentially
while somebody is still in
their critical section, so
what we need is an MSYNC here to ensure
that we first get the lock and only then
actually try to actually do our work in
the critical section so that our work
doesn't escape the critical section.
Now, another problem is that stores
in this processor can be reordered.
So we can easily release the lock and
then update the variable.
Which again we need to prevent.
So we need to prevent
that type of reordering.
We don't have to put an MSYNC here
because the load of the variable and
the store will happen in order.
because they're to
the same memory location.
And we don't have to put anything
here or anywhere in between because
all of these accesses to the lock
are going to be in program order anyway.
In general,
a lock function is considered to be
an acquire type of synchronization.
And then we put an MSYNC after it.
An unlock is considered to be
a release type of synchronization.
And we put the MSYNC before it.
So the idea is that you first acquire
access to something, then you MSYNC,
then you actually access it to make sure
that you access it after you acquire it.
And then when you want to release, you
first do what you want, then MSYNC, then
release to make sure that the release
actually happens after the work is done.
With flag synchronization we
have seen that waiting for
a flag is an acquire and that releasing
the flag is really a release.
And then a barrier is a weird case
where we have both an acquire and
a release in the same operation.
So we need an MSYNC both before and
after the barrier to ensure that
the work gets done before
we enter the barrier and
that nobody leaves until we
are done with the barrier.